will he give up his pipe
for a feminine wipe
what
i came up with that one i know
there was no question
well the guy who said i am what i am now
only answer to madame
the 93 year old comic strip popeye is
getting a makeover thanks to a busybody
cartoonist who promises fewer straight
characters and more ethnic diversity
it's exactly what fans of a 93 year old
comic strip watts
a non-binary pluto
artist randall milholland
explains i want to bring in more
characters who aren't heterosexual i
love this so much i don't live in that
purely straight white world and i don't
think a lot of other people do either
he's so brave
according to milan since popeye might
have worn a dress once by today's
definition popeye is gender fluid
so if you wear a dress that's gender
fluid someone better tell those guys in
kilts
that's a dress
of course many popeye stories featured
him firing down a can of spinach and
pummeling pluto after he tried to make a
move on olive oil who isn't attractive
i'm okay with saying that
but milhoun holland says i want to get
away from that i see these characters as
people who are sometimes mean to one
another but who do also care about each
other
that doesn't sound exciting at all i
don't watch roadrunner cartoons to see
him caring about wily e coyote
i watched them to see amazing new
products from the acme corporation
uh why did they sue of course
entertainment is no longer meant to
entertain only to let mediocrities like
randall sound important then again maybe
popeye does need a change i mean people
forget what those old cartoons were like
i remember this one
hey popeye tell your nosy broad to beat
it so we can get our pump on how dare
you speak to me like that zip it toots
why don't you take this spinach which is
for men only back to the kitchen we use
belongs
i want to try some
[Applause]
wow i finally have the energy to cook
clean and do house chores all day
the only thing a woman is good for
those were the good old days uh
a sexist would say please don't come to
me terrible terrible no this is right up
your alley for your book because this is
a now i'm assuming this is real right if
unless this guy is a master troll and
he's he's lampooning the woke because
he's using all the right lingo but i'm
gonna just assume that it's real this is
exactly what kind of your book is
focusing on where you're looking where
they they're applying political or
ideological things to stuff that's just
supposed to be fun yeah there's a lot of
this could actually just be for us yes
it's possible and as a commercial
decision it makes sense how else is
popeye going to be remotely relevant
unless it captures some of this
political eso but there is a moral
philosophy a framework being applied
here and you see it in disney and you
see it in half a dozen other
entertainment companies where you can't
just produce entertainment anymore
that's not important that's kind of
trite it has to have a social value it
has to be grander it has to serve this
purpose and even if we just even if it's
stilted and makes for bad art we have to
bludgeon you with this didactic
narrative because you're really not very
capable of catching a subtle narrative
where it's like you gotta force it on
this show
a moral
lesson don't spread your ignorance
around like manure young lady
continue smart man
no i'm done
sorry i'm just upset because you said
olive oil wasn't attractive and she and
i have the exact same body
are you
just insult my one representation of my
body in the media maybe you could be her
love her in the new popeye i mean i'd do
anything if they called made the call
yes exactly do you believe this
yeah i guess but the thing about this is
when it's contrived it tends to feel
contrived yes i didn't know
popeye was still doing stuff yeah
uh there probably are running of ideas
because 93 years is a long time so maybe
you know maybe that was why they really
wanted to do it they're like we've done
everything else so now he's non-binary
that could give another 93 years you
have bigger biceps than popeye you know
that but he has huge forearms massive
forward
actually his forearms are massive why
tires why is this four-arm so i thought
his forms look normal but whatever
um
you know the fact that him being
deformed in the face and the arms wasn't
enough for conclusion uh
gee i wonder with the new change of
characters what color pluto's going to
be seeing how he always kidnaps olive
makes her do things against her will
i wonder if
he's gonna end up black i'm just
spitting it out there you know like pepe
le pew probably gonna get a change
although he was handsy like pepe was out
of order
but these were cartoons but bugs bunny
had no problem putting a dress on a wig
and a lipstick and
tricking elmer to fall in love with him
in 30 seconds i mean
and we all laughed and cheered it on as
children like you know
you know
i remember being somewhat attracted to
when bugs was crossed yeah you literally
every to the only one who never fell
with it was the angry black duck that's
the only thing that they got right now
he was angry lately you're questioning
would hate him we label you questioning
yes yes i'm questioning you know but i
mean it was like i would choose bugs
bunny in drag over jessica rabbit yeah
really yeah yeah you lost me there yeah
well i don't know i mean i don't know
one thing that is that is amusing about
about this is that just when you think
there's no way they're actually going to
defend something you can push them a
little bit further so with the disney
thing for example when they had that
zoom call that came out and the head of
content it wasn't just some random
person that disney said you know we need
more pansexual characters and this was
for for cartoons a lot of us are saying
first of all what is pansexual to which
the blue czech mafia online says how can
you not know what that is you say well
what about omnisexuals and then all of a
sudden everyone says hold on a second
what does that mean they look for the
next thing you can always say where is
the representation of and just make
something up right and the left will
freak out about it
you come up with something you're just
like honestly not enough vegan
astronauts who are oppressed and they
will all of a sudden say
we need to put more of those in our
content you're right because if they
exclude anybody then the whole house of
cards starts to fall down another
favorite one by the way if they ever
just say lgbtq what about the ia plus
sir yeah they flip they say i'm sorry
they don't say that is the longest
acronym in the history of acronyms and
this has gotten absurd like they they
have to have everything or else they
have nothing i just don't know if it's i
wonder if this is going to come out to
be an elaborate ruse because it's just
too crazy you should go i mean does he
still get to keep the pipe or is it
going to be a vape i don't know i don't
know i mean it's popeye the sailor man
don't change that don't turn him into a
birthing person
although pluto could identify as a trans
female and compete in male cartoon
sports
all right we gotta move on enough of
this crap
up next another clip of hunter's cheap
thrills while the big guy paid his bill
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else